[Music]
thanks to DVRs not as many people watch
television commercials anymore as well
yeah speed through them and it's too bad
because here's the thing I feel bad
about a lot of hard work a lot of
creativity a lot of production goes into
making television commercials so I
thought we'd take a look
shine a spotlight on some of the really
good work yeah and retaining yeah look
at some of these commercials and a piece
we're calling commercial reviews okay
our first commercial is for Yoplait
yogurt now Yoplait ads are usually just
geared towards women but i wanted to
focus on this commercial because this
and this one the man gets some equal
time and i thought was worth looking at
my diet well yesterday i had an apple
turnover mm-hmm i know it's sort of my
weakness i always keep it in the house
well that and Boston cream pie wait
chocolate strawberries yeah yeah key
lime pie
I've already lost some weight Yoplait
light with 14 delicious flavors at 100
calories babe what are you doing oh I
don't know maybe I'm looking for all of
the desserts you just finished listing
who talks about yogurt that way oh I'm
eating all of these pies and I'm losing
all this weight by eating pies up yours
I'm sick of all your passive-aggressive
BS sorry I looked for desserts that you
just said we're in the house
I want a divorce yogurt is really good I
[Music]
thought this next commercial was for the
NFL or Direct TV but I had to watch the
entire commercial to realize I was wrong
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
mutual of Omaha's backwards
[Applause]
rulers because death alert believe
that's the slogan they're going with now
catchy slogan anything
this next commercials what's a very
unusual celebrity endorsement from
professional skier Lindsey Vonn it's an
incredible feeling
you can try to describe it but words
really can't do it justice your heart's
pounding your pulse is racing it's a
real adrenaline rush and once you've
experienced it you want to experience it
again and again it's addictive that way
[Music]
I guess that's her thing
finally the ads for craft milk bite bars
feature a cute but very sad little
puppet and I was kind of surprised to
see just how dark and depressing Kraft
was willing to go with these commercials
you didn't think did you you uh you
didn't think what life was gonna be like
for me mom dad look bite bars are made
with real tasty
[Music]
those parts are full like yeah they're
packed with blood a lot of blood
yeah for a little bar